tomorrow is a new day for israel a new
government is expected to be sworn in
ending the long and often rocky tenure
of prime minister benjamin netanyahu
in his place an unlikely coalition that
includes for the first time
a party from israel's arab minority it's
a political shakeup that will have its
work cut out for itself
charlie dagetta reports
violence erupts again on the streets of
east jerusalem
riot police fired stun grenades to
disperse palestinian protesters
the trigger this time right-wing
politician itamar ben veer
contesting police orders postponing a
planned march
why did you decide to come today because
this
is jerusalem he said it is our country
and
our capital hamas militants call it
provocative and aggressive
and while small in scale they're exactly
the kind of street battles that quickly
escalated
into a full-blown conflict in gaza last
month
a dark omen of the volatile days ahead
as israel swears in a new government on
sunday
pushing prime minister benjamin
netanyahu out of a record
12 years in power netanyahu has called
it the worst election fraud in the
history of democracy
and stands accused of inciting violence
among his most
fervent supporters former prime minister
ehud barak told us
they better accept that netanyahu's
political days
are over you come here back in three
months after
netanyahu left our office and people
will not believe how fast he he went
out of the focus of of the
interest of the public and how profound
change had been had been achieved
in the first serious test for the new
government police have allowed that
right
wing march to take place on tuesday that
risks
not only street clashes but hamas rocket
attacks
in retaliation for cbs this morning
saturday charlie dagetta tel aviv